you
all right I have not got a competed in
one of these before and definitely not
after just finishing a cyma but we're
going to give it a go this is an elite
bullet arena you have to have 30 bullet
games rated and you have to have a
certain rating level so everything will
be tough who doesn't get tougher than uh
well sure it gets tougher but a tough
first round for sure every round will be
tough
Shrek and David in round one of who
knows how many Oh
this isn't high per bullet I am up a
piece I feel like my mouse is not the
greatest I want my night on f5 yeah I'm
a lagging some here Queen trade
threatening a fork oh they missed the
fork yeah this isn't good mmm I don't
know I wonder if I have to close out of
some tabs let me try to close out of
some tabs here maybe that'll help I
wonder what my ping is out I think it's
usually right around that so that's not
that's not anything okay my neighbor's
going with the timely weed-whacking well
done but last time I pointed that out
you guys said that you really couldn't
hear that so it's good news you don't
you don't need to be here that stuff
that stuff Oh who's going to be
dangerous under five let's watch out for
that we don't want that night bringing
the pain do we what a dancer my night is
not doing something similar in this game
as I did last with this manoeuvre get
out there got no business being there
just keep the Queen's on huh it's going
to be broken down night into a four all
right
on the clock let's kill the night Queen
f6 if my knight is challenged on f4 get
this dog and opened up maybe the H file
opens up maybe I guard some squares over
here that and I can't move there's a
cost connected with it I would love to
see this move Knight you know you want
to move got to stop that knife from
moving and ooh I need to clog up the C
file yes with that move they move really
fast just then
I have a good edge on the clock oh boy
take the pawn if the knight moves jump
on in
Queen check Oh watch out for smothered
watch out for the smothered mate check
oh I love these guided chicks it's not
quite mate he grabbed at night five
seconds
where's the mate there it is back to
tournament
Zeus thank you so much for using that
Amazon Prime perk man appreciate the
support the channel all right we got
four
I should probably pace myself huh
face yourself there's there's only 24 in
here for everyone's a tough cookie tough
cookie
all right let's launch three ponds
if Hutch is in fact watching right now I
think he's hosting he's probably saying
three three ponds man I've ramified
before three is nothing you haven't
played chess until you've launched a
five pound attack let's pin that Knight
see how my father feels about that
grab a timely tempo let's insist on this
pin Queens unprotected my light squares
are weakened I can't take my bishop just
yet
now you could let's back up Oh going to
grab a pawn at the end of this aren't ya
on the rook oh this is a little bit
uncomfortable Bishop takes pawn right
now is a good move or even right now
okay not now no because it's not there
I'm not sure what this is doing this is
going to come down to a rat race officer
colored bishops you can see this game
having like 200 moves to it just a lot
of moves which is a lot of moves 16
guard that seven
it's important I'm going to throw into
check because they like to time burn I
have some kind of okay I'm grabbing upon
Ron pon I should be able to win this I
have enough confidence in my mouse in
fact he's bolting it's Usain Bolt right
there
lots of saying this right now
that's a pin where's the mates where's
the mates
they got moves with the king who okay
back to tournament
twelve eight twelve it's just a small
crew but everyone is beefy twelve eight
seven with fire hmm okay this is the top
dog I imagine we're going to this won't
be the only time we get paired up all
righty I'm going to go at c5 huh I see
we're going to go for some space and I
guess here
gone to d3 okay they're gonna crack with
um f6 I guess not I think I could sneak
my queen in or my knight in he should be
pretty good here no no no he's not
pretty good there let's try and stir up
some trouble so much for well actually
this could work cuz I could take here
with tempo I'm on the rook push yeah
where's that where's that Queen go and
she's scaring me
let's just make something active
actually I was just ready to make an
illegal move I need to keep a rook on
let's do it let's grab this pawn then
you're going to take my rook in the
corner no okay that's that's too much
this pawn is going to be a bother
in my King's help yeah
trouble town trouble town huh I got
nothing but the clock and that's not
going to be enough I just looked that
pawn room for a touchdown
hmm yeah I should probably resign huh
three seconds stalemates stalemates I
love stalemates look at how I weaved a
stalemate never give up never give up
stalemate okay I'll take every little
point I could get two I got two for that
but the fire has been extinguished Oh
King versus Queen rook and a few ponds
everybody knows I was winning that oh
it's too much fun it's too much fun and
I don't know too much fun
let's Castle it's important watch out
for the great advice castle it's
important you're not going to want to
drop your beep on oh I don't know what
to say oh they're gonna go here very
nice
let me get hey with the fork look at
this all right
down on time and position but I've seen
worse I've seen worse definitely seen
worse I could have captured that pond ah
there was a pin already going on I
didn't have to play b4 there in the
think tank though this this pond kills a
two go ahead
double up I so want to take that pond I
don't think it's working
yeah I'm threatening to take the pond
you can't you can't avoid that now you
have to play rook c1 there we go
who's being tricky now I'm actually
getting the rook can't save the rook
I'll take him if he's free and now we
pushed some ponds around side steps any
any tricks hang on
keep pushing your pawns push we're going
to go with the fork they're down on time
they really went into the think tank on
that one huh
they went into the think tank alright um
or Timmy's lol I'm probably butchering
your name thank you for the sub man
thanks for supporting the channel
okay listen sky again I got away with a
clearly got away with one stalemate it's
this guy again the top dog
all righty all right I don't mind seeing
this we're gonna we're going to get rid
of all all the pieces all right I have
gg3 is very weakened but without any
minor pieces around there shouldn't be
much of a bother
let's watch out for the minority attack
a minority attack um here
Queen exchange they're really fast it's
what you would expect
speedy my king needs to drift over
towards the Queen side ASAP okay so
they're going to hunt down my pawn my
King needs to come over right over here
careful now careful that a pawn could
fall they're ready to undermine I might
be able to track that pond down what's
this about oh you get in back where's my
opponent getting that guy back let's see
can't trade all right Oh
that's what they're doing oh they're
just tracking everything down like they
did in the last game um yeah I'm not
getting invading that I have a passed
pawn though I could work with this no
let's go here then they have ten seconds
run King check
they're doing time burners yes I got the
final time burner I think every games
gonna be like that okay we got forth to
you a fire don't blink don't blink you
might miss a time burning move okay
also don't be listening with headphones
not a good idea let's go let's go with
the Caro Oh dr. Seuss he's back oh
that's a quick d5 okay that's a check
that's check you got a block with the
night they know this this come off like
I'm trying to coach my opponent you got
this is what you got to do some some
people are saying why why is he trying
to help his opponents why would he do
something like that oh boy awkward how
about a knight on e5 isn't that
beautiful
d3 even more beautiful
hmm
get out of there you're scaring me okay
oh boy it's scary around here okay they
have tricks here they have tricks oh but
my knight likes that pawn I think I need
to do that get this clean on here
twenty-two seconds my opponent is lying
lying that's a free bishop though why'd
I go there where I could be checked
sixteen seconds there's a check there we
go we got some good stuff happening
right check I'm defending here check
drive smothered mate stuff I've packed
rank stuff ah pawn is pinned I could go
fast at least I could go really fast I
got the Queen oh man no stalemates that
was ready stalemate
their King had some steel mating idea
avoid the stalemates grab pawns run for
your life not doing it the greatest way
staircase you love the staircase your
favorite holy cow my heart is in my
throat
21:18 with fire oh 32 players whoa okay
okay okay calm down calm down you can't
keep up this pace for the whole
tournament there's still an hour and 10
left slow down whoo man easy now easy
now no no no no no no no we're not going
to Castle too soon we don't want any
fancy sacrifices on h3 now you know and
that's what you're lining up and so you
would be lining up I just know it drop
in here could have capture that pond you
goof want to break down this Center
let's take and enter how are they
defending that I have v8 controlled I
love Queen exchanges now there's no
attack this is still good yeah
my knight will be there to do some good
things let's just go here feels active
it feels active all right dark square
bishop exchange Bishop takes pawn lined
up
now we're cooking connected passers and
now push through incoming King a four
here next I got this covered enough
that's a check
you get pushing I could block that check
got a queen in a time edge they should
be resigning they are back to tournament
all right we have a lead this might be
the only lead the tournament will see 22
with fire and our eight left that's all
that's all just an hour and eight
oh man
there's no breathers there are no
breathers in this one let's let's not
counsel too soon yeah they might have
gone for a crazy attack against my king
we don't want that I don't know let's
try for Queen a5 Bishop d7 keep pressure
on c4 reinforced d5 with Bishop b7 stop
a3 clean exchange yeah v5 it should be
seven alright Bishop sluice piece um
flight square mmm I should have come
over with my King God take it to my
bishop um oh I don't have a move here oh
well well maybe maybe I have something I
have rook activity I wasted so much time
there though let's grab this pawn and
that one secured my bishop their Bishop
and Knight are not playing that's the
only uh that's good okay actually I'm
getting this back office of color
bishops I have two ponds let's lock that
that down get my king over here
I'm lucky too okay to even be in this
position
get on the light squares okay oh they're
grabbing an important pawn they don't
have much time fought back on the clock
they were being sneaky they're being
sneaky there
okay we got this no stalemates no
stalemates that's mate back to
tournament oh-6 hh6 was a dud and a half
that was not cool at all
yeah that was not cool h6
I need to get my king over to the center
as soon as possible my seventh rank was
really really weakened all right I like
this setup you didn't know solid it's
simple it's good for bullets I think at
least alright I can't get to B for now I
like my Center improve my king let's go
here just make sure that this file
doesn't open up there Knight needs to
move but he can't move oh man I just
allowed a juicy fork there a juicy fork
ah
I have a center that's about it and the
king that is gone crazy I think my
knight needs to get here their King is
so good man I think I need to do this
their king is so good you have to do
that is this close to mate feels like
it's close
oh let's resign ah I for I actually
overlooked that that was even a move um
would like when I'm oh I got another
game already when I made the King move I
didn't even realize that that rook
captures pawn was a move I wasn't I
wasn't doing that to avoid that capture
with check I just didn't even see that
that was a move rook takes pawn that was
not cool haha man I gave up b4 that
wasn't good that was painful
okay let's get cancelled time burner no
I'll grab a center pond why not I mean
really why not what's keeping you from
that okay oh I should probably get out
of this pin huh I have the F for square
gotta back up my Queen wants to be
somewhere else let's get active Knight
f4 should make them think at least there
we go hitting everything and that's me
just like that you see what happens when
a knight gets on f4
he can make it look simple but it's
really it's not as simple as that night
on f4 is very strong though night on f4
white King on g1 yeah black night on a5
black King on g8 King side castle scary
pieces those nights super strong ok
universe
okay we're going to have mass exchanges
this is not the as you can see not our
first game and this is not the first
time we're playing like this we both we
both enjoy major we both enjoy endings I
think we both like having a minor pieces
gone maybe should have captured the
other way it's a pressure on this guy so
you follow up and up soon after watch
out for Knight g5 yeah that's what
they're lining up I want to prepare to
take that night out if he gets on g5
let's open up the C file I get in there
no okay it looks ugly I think I have to
do it Queen on f6 or f7 controls some
squares over here to c4
now they could take boy night here is
that a pin they cannot get out of I now
the night can return to d4 but there uh
in the think tank there I'm just
dropping the pond king of seven oh boy
run for your life right there let's come
over here I guess I want to see the pond
now he can't push I could take oh that's
going to be a killer gonna be dangerous
night very dangerous night they don't
have any time though yeah I could go
time burning two seconds careful they're
down on time
determine man ok 30 with fire 26 right
on my heels 22 22 1637 in this one were
just under now the hour mark okay
let's see who we get a little bit of a
wait here for a game that's all right I
can use the breather oh there we go
again ah I got hit with the fork I will
revisit that position though for sure
mmm let's challenge that Bishop I
definitely am a fan of these structures
oh I didn't see that they moved there I
don't have sound on so sometimes I am
miss moves let's challenge b5 um let's
go here I have a five reply to b4 I
somehow did not see that move as well
here I guess more exchanges and now in
the end I have excellent square for my
rook okay this is a huge target remove
the glues the name of the game here the
bishop is the glue get rid of the glue
we're going to dance a little bit
they're going to avoid that exchange
I'll try something else though I'll go
here if the bishop goes to e4 of force
black's hand and stop this break i have
control over the only open file let's
stop queen here that could be annoying
let's pick up the pawn and now i'm
welcome to exchanges mass exchanges am i
king defend this pawn let's have a
complete lockdown over here
Brook enters uh they're gonna they're
going to pile up there let's get this
pond running some let's keep the rook on
I should have gone here sooner
I want the Queen's off oh I got the
Queen's off fortunately I should be able
to get this they're threatening mate
timely pin got the Queen should have
figured they would do something sneaky
like that this is this is alright
my rook is like pac-man like pac-man no
stalemates I'm stalemates there we go
back to tournament well he didn't go
into pac-man but
he took upon and then we pushed that
pawn got a Queenie 34 30 24 22 whoo
yeah this is what I would expect someone
in the chat saying uh listener gaining
ground of course a see three Sicilian
when do I play this rarely okay
let's try to work with this pawn here
huh Knight f4
timely tempo let's put pressure on d6 so
reinforced my e5 pawn Bishop d7 rook to
c1 the Queen can't feel too comfortable
being opposite my rook let's get all my
pieces working Queen here at some point
will threaten mate um oh I could go here
I have that Square supported and I think
Queenie for I want to do really really
soon they're just giving me the fishhook
huh I'm up a piece yeah they resigned
back determine third ooh little Plotkin
okay let's jump in I think we've played
a game before where they were in prima
mode and they moved their Bishop there
yeah okay let's recirculate this Knight
to e5 that's not the right term not
recirculating anything okay we got a
challenge that night let's take at the
pawn I have some kind of imbalance in
the position Queen on b7 makes that
advance more difficult let's double up
this is where the attention is flight
Square chop-chop watch out for Forks
that pawns falling or is he or is he not
cook isn't shuffle all right King
hide I don't know h4 h5 Knight here
Queen c5 push that
here it's a pin Fon attack the paint
upon night night right here
don't drop your queen um seems
interesting
job for the four
Mark's keep that pin 10 seconds though
oh no time in no time
not sure if that move is doing I need to
get from I don't need to go for mate can
I get a mates Oh two seconds
never do two seconds need to get all the
pawns ah that night is so tricky that
night is so tricky man uh me and I just
want to rely upon a color a light or
dark but no I explained this before I
think it was the last dream yeah I
already went on a little bit of a rant
about the night and how he keeps you on
your toes it's just it's just what he
does well oh man
tricky tricky tricky miss you pawn grab
her the assassins gonna kill me for that
one oh really
yeah my king is sneaky though he's a
slippery King a slippery King
he's living dangerous um the air take
that Oh living on the edge on the edge
you ready to go here I know you're up -
get out of my house oh boy here I guess
a car you live on that square I think
the worst is over
he spoke too soon the worst really isn't
over yes it is there you go you
weathered the storm now put that extra
piece you have to use there you go
you got a time edge and everything let's
just run away be a scaredy-cat it's okay
to be a scaredy-cat sometimes a
scaredy-cat where's the mate hang onto
that night I'm on edge too
excellent clean there King cannot move
Queen takes one check I don't announce
the checks in case you're wondering
but I'm announcing and we got a rook and
they have to block now we got them in a
pin and there we go
Forks here we go now stalemates they got
pawns they can move that's mate next
back to Turman as scary the very least
though scary
Knight takes f7 King running for his
life if I went to g8 there's Queen e6
okay he's on a tear he's got five in a
row five fours fours are tough to come
by easy to get your uh you know easy to
get extinguished okay I'm still trying
to get some fire here that's very
aggressive let's play in the center
the book says that's what the book says
so we're going to do with what the book
says oh boy am I in trouble I might be
in trouble I am in trouble how do you
untangle man how do you untangle we're
gonna try something fancy yeah this is
really fancy really fancy can I get that
night back I could okay
barely barely let's hang onto Center
Pond they're getting the Jeep on they
don't want them it's castle okay
here I guess my rook on this square is
stupid I got some light square
weaknesses let's get over here
post up in the center I'm going to push
my bishops around on there light square
bishop I want to break this down before
they close it up oh my knight oh it's a
good thing he's controlling this square
I didn't realize it's important
I want my knight here
I got a fork say him 14 seconds now we
take now we give a check I have a fork
there it is he's dangerous
huh I felt like that night could have
promoted got him checks checks more
checks and we got a queen and that's
mate I'll take it
46 42 28 24
oh man this is an intense tournament I
haven't a first-time elites the Alita
bullet tournament is what it's called
okay a Carol con with mainline 92 let's
see how they take their writing I should
have gone with the night I should have
gained some tempo against the bishop oh
well
what kind of a flight square do I want I
guess don't light square my queens
defending that night who is now short on
squares and my night is getting chased
around pawn push is good I think I need
to stop that yeah well done I have to
work around that guy
no dislodging him or is there or is
there that Queen needs to go for
starters and this night you need to get
out of here you need to get out of here
hope I have everything defended barely
oh they're giving me this pawn it's
important pawn no on the bishop how do
we get out five running huh my rook rook
will play one day one day I need to get
out of the pin let's take first here
there's no I could take here with check
ah how about this Queen takes bishop I'm
on the rook they might miss that they're
not missing that I have this move hope
it's working
mmm time burning stuff Oh got made the
Queen Esther block okay let's cut the
King off I just want to hide my king I
could tie and burn my way out with this
one
no stalemates or not stalemates but no a
repetition they're down on time okay
someone needs to Nick this guy 54 he's
still running with fire he's got all
fours get him get him
why are the withdraws don't withdraw
get back in there here he is I have my
chance both games I've played against
him I should have lost
yeah but I managed I managed what
exactly a draw and a win okay I like
this opening up here I could do this now
where's that Nikon I want to get into h6
hmm a little bit scary
sure hmm
I'm on the night and I have a check here
clean here runs into mate I think now
the Queen's defending this is going with
some trades that move yeah okay they
have a huge time edge yeah they're
defending everything my queens active
though grab that pond yikes clean on BA
fortunately
Rek isn't playing the time is catching
up they're calculating this stuff yeah
they're going to take that pawn with
check nice the
have to block
mm he Ike's yeah
now the pons pushing yep nice sequence
being able to capture that F pawn with
check that was very good 58 46 that's a
big loss to that extends his lead the
top dog 5846 28 27 43 and a half left
all right let's see who we got next
there's 46 in here now already
first-time opponent let's see what we
could get here got to get back on the
horse got to get that fire back real
soon okay
oh it's Castle right to c8 I have a
two-to-one in the center maybe get these
guys rolling at some point unsent rise
my knight
let's take let's avoid that capture
they're just giving up okay they're just
playing for some fast stuff in a solid
structure let's get my queen off of the
same file how about we pile up on the
seat pond now oh I got this covered my
queen still need a flight square let's
get it in there let's take this Knight
starting to look too dangerous
rook entry stuff as well improve the
king it's a good move
stop rook to b6 maybe we triple up
actually I'm hitting these two now tough
to defend let's grab the a pawn stop h5
and bring the King queen back over all
right
winning upon now sort of like how my
opponent did in the last game let's mop
up this whole side here and make sure
the Queens are off whoo just giving me
the Queen the king was too excited to
run he continues okay I have another
chance come on you're going to tackle
this guy you got to stop him right now
okay
they're going to win that pond give up
the dark square Bishop greedy can't
believe you're playing greedy okay let's
get castle before it's too late
get rid of that Knight
okay we're going to play against this
structure I think it's okay to do it
like this could play without the Queen's
on the bishop I have an excellent night
I may be better till that move where's
that Bishop gone guard my seventh prove
the King I want a rook trade think yeah
like I'd do that huh I could track that
pond down though the king is not in time
slippery King he could get running
though no the King goes here he can't uh
he's he's sort of in Maitland no close
to it this stops the pawn from moving
and so I have to be careful yet yeah
let's get pawns on light squares first
now I get to take that with check
they'll probably resign here I have a
time edge as well that's important win
finally now
I don't get paired up for with them for
a while and I get some fours in somebody
else maybe can knock them off less than
40 60 to 50 34 alright 49 players in
here now I got fire this next one is
important give me a form I'm needing a
four I'm not getting a pairing though I
can look at the chat our Connie TV is in
there gar tiger is in there we got bad
chicken on board okay
eight Queen side fianchetto huh okay
give me the H file give me the H file
take my bishop take my bishop take my
bishop take my [ __ ] up okay
force my hand I think now I have
discovered
I have that covered so now I could look
to shut down this guy let's do it
before d4 is in there now this night
struggles I'm looking for this I want to
stop c3 and maybe even post up here yeah
let's do this I'm controlling the night
very well that's important my nights
under fire let's protect them in a
sneaky way a sneaky way I'm done being
sneaky they're really going to go up on
hunting all right I'm doing this just so
I could get a nice clean position here
yeah this is a not better for me
Queens are off can I get that pawn mmm I
don't know
gotta get here fast don't know where I
want to go with my night ah now I want
to trade a grabbing an important pond 13
seconds um yeah it's big trouble for me
all right I had to be sneaky there had
to be sneaky and I have much time and
I'm getting a queen please avoid Forks I
got the knight wits check the pawn with
check and another pawn I could track
down who okay don't stay on mates
get in the corner Knight back determine
64-54 38 36 in change okay got that for
need another one
he won his next game alright d4 Knight
f3 c4 I'm just I'm just announcing moves
no commentary just announced the moves
just just let people know the notation
that's what they want they want to hear
the notation okay let's hang on to that
guy clean exchange now
no thanks how about b4 there we go
Bishop takes a three minority attack all
right what next okay let's break they
might have oh really
really I guess it is working man
well definitely four bullet you know got
me thinking at least burn some seconds
there whoa careful now
Stella Brooke h4 watch out for mates my
Knights a good defender let's get this
rook off Chuck stay active Queen here oh
boy
scary around here my rook needs to do
something
there's no rook
with check my Queens defended anyhow the
attack is no longer there on the night
and I could take the rook it's a check
let's just be safe I'll give up the
Queen I got a night that could defend
like an animal back to tournament
excellent defender that Knight is
against Queen checks clean perpetual
66-58 still plenty of time in this 134
minute mark okay we need another four
he's playing in a game right here the
number one dog I think black has a good
position
well now dropped upon there all right
let's try c6o karo
okay what's that move about a little
sequence a little finesse there Bishop
b5 Bishop d3 I could have taken the
night no yes or no let's let's be
aggressive about that throw your queen
out there hope for the best
that's how you do it that's the way
forward launch a jeep on so much for
that attack huh um let's go break in the
center it's scary
oh they really have that all right we're
going to
these guys try to alright let me try to
hunt down this pawn so much for that
these policy be scary now my King needs
to play my King doesn't play I could
forget about this one can I get that
pond
to hang on to that one can I get him I
think I got him
Knight right here nice move nice move
why did I do that
ah mmm no good no good
oh that's I'm glad I'm out slip that one
glad i mouse slipped I should have made
that King move sooner could take the
pawn and defend here they're going for a
drama so you're going for get back over
there can I tie and burn my way to
victory No
no no
hold her down in time time burning
tactics seventy sixty two both have fire
up here he's in a game yes he is and it
looks like he will be picking up another
one that is a beast right there you have
to look closed I know it's smaller on
the stream here but that's a beast it's
a beast right there on f5 f4 you know
what I meant
'if I've I don't know how about d5 some
type of a gambit huh let's challenge
that night my night is going to get
kicked away huh
I don't know why I'm playing like this
not quite sure Bishop takes pawn
I get the bishop back oof should have
played Bishop to e2 dodged a bullet
there huh
rook f8 whoa that's already game over
got everything back to tournament I won
paid off 74-66 that was not objectively
good lucky lucky lucky
30 minutes 23 seconds okay eight back
still he's in a game that could happen
any moment doesn't seem like it's gonna
finish any time soon he's up a piece
he's going to win that one the assassin
white it's the one who had my King
running for the hills when I grabbed
that C pawn all right Caesar a little
bit more comfortable here they're gonna
give me the H file yeah Wow
all right let's take and play e4 I want
a five and now sneak into the Lodi h6
square the bishop will be there to
defend oh no going over here hmm Queen
there I want to keep the Queen's on the
Queen will be there to defend oh nice
move man nice move nice well done
can I put some pressure on though and
take that got to try something
I'm not down a piece I thought I'm down
a piece
I'm not down a piece they take upon
Angie yeah it was a pond I thought it
was a piece I was like Oh dropping uh
I'm dropping a knight or something now
that was a pawn back to basics man you
have to learn the names of pieces now
uh-oh f5 is gonna hurt me how to break
down the structure before the King moves
finally got that in there
check check guard my seventh ship check
a rook check oh my good as I can't name
pieces forget about it you could take
upon to
rook takes pawn i doing
yeah checks any checks keep the rock on
time boy it's tough to commentate 78
with fire 7042 seems like it'll be
between us to up here hmm
still eight back he's in a game he's on
his way to winning another 152 players
okay I have to get this one he's gonna
have eighty two before you know it I
don't think he berserk that one yeah I
haven't really seen I don't know if
anyone's bruiser 'king probably not the
greatest tournament to try berserk and
berserk in' alright let's go all the way
back hmm not a fun structure at all got
this pawn hmm let's hang out of the pond
then d5 let's get my king over
when's my dark squared bishop going to
play now
I think I need to give him up it's too
much of an inconvenience grab here and
I'll take here and then here that night
would be too much of a bother
well he's a bother anyhow let's I have
to challenge him I should have grabbed
another pond I want it I want to
undermine the night I'm able to do that
but - it's getting really active oh man
it's ready to hurt me
let's get this pond going 24 seconds
grab a pond probably the wrong one yeah
threatening mates though um I want to I
want to shift this King away and then
take the night and then push through can
I make that happen
um I'm floundering I'm floundering no I
think I'm helping out there King ten
seconds
Oh
oh man
oh he's pinned they got a check of any
time
they're down on time oh man oh man click
click click click miss click illegal
move click click don't talk whatever you
do don't talk just keep clicking maybe
you'll find a legal move right just try
just trial and error it's trial there
that I was going with right then this is
legal is this legal let's try King here
nope and the legal move try again try
again back to basics we enjoy this line
we definitely are enjoying this line I
don't have the better now this isn't a
good line for me to be revisiting now
it's just not so I'm gonna have to baby
dat this pawn it's not fun but that's
what I signed up for that's what I get
that's what I get yeah you could just be
hunted down huh it's that simple
let's grab something yeah okay I am
target practice right now it's just how
it is I'm defending though I've pressure
against the b-pawn so that's nice
careful there being fancy there mmm I
think I could do this where is that
queenie going my king needs to get over
here some space man space i don't know
where he's going don't know where he's
going
i want to get my queen here get a check
in there I got a check hmm they're
allowing that huh huh
I don't know it's going to be a timer a
time thing and go for a queen trade
we're even on the clock
no to keep the Queens on I knew they're
going to go for that
oh the Queen's are going to be off
you
oh man
oh I'm a guessing machine I'm a guessing
machine I love it oh I needed to be a
guessing machine eighty-eight 76-42 my
luck ran out though at the end there dra
oh man okay I can't revisit that opening
man I mean unless I like being tortured
I don't like being tortured I was
tortured in that one oh man
stay away from that that was bad news
my poor c-pawn man I felt so bad for him
I should have captured that night all
right they gave me another chance you're
going to want to defend your epon I
don't know one of the more purposeful
moves you'll see right there
Ford f6 try it once try it at least once
you know there we go
that's the kind of support I was looking
for all right Knight Queen Knight wants
to be over here this is where there's
some juicy stuff happening I think okay
night on g5 something has to something
has to happen now we're going to avoid
the rook exchange there's any attempt
for a rook exchange we're going to avoid
it let's reinforce the center and
prepare to crash through on h3 keep the
knight around he's hungry that is a
hungry Knight the F Vaughn wants to play
oh yeah the F pawns playing
by giving up material why did I do that
I'm not losing material but I need some
more fuel that's a thorn isn't it here
and then double let's push to get rid of
this rook I think it's too good of a
defender defend that pawn I want them to
take that oh there we go I collapsed
where's the mate right around the corner
down on time back to Terman 88-78
ten back neither of us have fire because
of that draw
okay
here we go is he in the game yeah they
might be waiting for us to uh I think
we're gonna get paired up again whoo
okay yeah he just finished so I guess
we're gonna get paired god I get this
one it's important to make a comeback am
I getting an excessive amount of whites
I mean I don't mind but is this really
fair
not that I'm putting it to use you know
not really putting it to use
all right I gotta get this guy man gotta
get him okay can I get that pond back is
that what's happening I guess I guess
that's what's happening okay hmm
you pond grabber you sneaky I get that
guy huh triple up on the f7 pond is what
I want can I manage that rook takes pawn
maybe at least they're thinking how are
they defending okay they're going with
that
I'm a passed pawn though okay my king
needs to come over here fast don't know
is really going to work though I think I
need to shift gears my king needs to
stay over here I think the rook is going
to be so active though that's a good
move
let's give this check got to come back
they're giving and getting that pond
yeah I took a passive approach not cool
they could inch their way all the way
down this was not a good idea hmm
yeah this was so so poor of an attempt
that was silly back to tournament not
even a good fight in that 192 with fire
mmm that's tough now 92 78 42 hmm had my
chances not in that game but I'm
definitely getting my chances against
him but I'm not making the best of him
okay all right do I have to go like
crazy town do I have to try stuff that's
out of my comfort zone
like wild attacking stuff to get some
quick wins I don't know yeah they're
squashing that idea their night into f6
Knight into f6 Knight into f6 is what I
want they're going to push Knight takes
I get that move in hmm that is tough
pawn to track down and grab that pawn
not playing fast I'm in trouble I could
get that pawn back maybe maybe not oh
well so much for an attack got a queen
position it could have captured an f4
for h5
can I get that pond back I need to kick
the night away okay I'm up a pond now
can I trap that night think he's should
have a let's try it this way
you have to play a five I think now can
I get that night need to try to get that
night um not easy okay I got that pond
no repetition thought it might be rapid
too
there for a second oh really
ah man and I'm down on time no good man
no good I was trying to be sneaky with
my beep on push was there just not a way
to trap that night I couldn't figure it
out I was wasting so much time trying to
trap that night double goose eggs is no
good hmm 14 minutes okay this is
probably the last try he's going with b3
okay we got the black side maybe I could
do better on the black end who knows
okay hanging pawn structure let's put
some pressure on it huh Knight a5 really
really fast Bishop f4 let's centralize
hang on to the Bishop g4 will I be
trapped I have this move should probably
challenge this Knight really soon there
Bishop is dangerous okay scary oh I had
the wrong pre move in there they took
the other piece let's go here okay I
could really use a queen exchange I
think um however mmm
think I could do this because I could
come back here could take the pond if
Rick G - but not on that move but in the
end I have this slight time edge and I'm
better now definitely slightly better
structure let's take this pond and get
one rock off let's hang on to this one
now I have something similar that they
had okay
now applying this the best at all okay
that's helpful
they take they're not going to take
they're not they have to hide behind the
pond
Oh
oh man
what am i doing oh my goodness they're
down on time and on the other second oh
I have no idea what I was trying to do I
was trying to weasel with that uh trying
to waste try to pull off that little
staircase thing I couldn't sort it out
it's like wait this is the Queen go here
in the the rook oh here where's my King
DeLong just get out of the way King go
in the corner and hide get out of the
way everybody can relate to that right
he just you just want certain pieces out
of the way and they don't get out of the
way yeah what's he talking about you got
to do yourself man
and just move automatically you got to
move them okay we don't want to run into
Bishop f4 with Sefo doing no we don't
oh you're Iying up this square I know
you are go for it I dare you
is this what you're going for perpetual
oh my goodness can't believe you tried
that I don't want to draw I can't afford
to draw no he's tricky and I need him
and I'm gonna try to show you how tricky
he can be yes we're just gonna wait for
you oh I will take him now all right I
still the night oh yeah here we go Forks
around the corner
all right over here
session
careful careful now careful I have a
time edge get rid of that a double pawn
careful don't run away my knight my
knight wants you over here then checking
distance careful let's go at the check
oh there could might be mates right
around the corner there is a fork got
him there it is
I could have captured that pawn I had
this covered let's do it like this there
we go
I knew he would come back he's a fighter
that night he's a fighter that night 98
82 I got fire nine Oh
all right let's try Knight f3 and c4
this is the pack leader I definitely
need to get this running out of attempts
gonna grab that pawn again let's hang on
to him come all the way back Bishop c4
is annoying castle by hand I guess I
guess
hmm Wow sharp man sharp move yeah that's
a sharp move I think he could take care
okay that ponds gonna fall
I got a push huh they gave me that night
they just plundered whoa would not have
expected that happen though its trade
and clean exchange
okay hit the rook count the bishop off
and Bishop off think this is okay okay
clean exchange let's give a check offer
another exchange get the King out of
harm's way
on my night on g5 now we could get this
get this pawn as soon as possible how
annoying
man and get this pawn
you
huh
you
oh I'm down on time oh man being up a
piece
I'm not going to catch him either
86 to 98 I still should have had that
though my goodness being up a piece I
was lucky to be up a piece ah I did not
convert that that King got so active
should not have allowed that in the King
to get so active ah man notice what I
did there you knows what I just did
right there I'm like well well I I you
know I would have been able to win
anyhow so it's okay that I lost no no
it's not okay that you just lost that
game win that game it's not okay to lose
that game play better chess play better
chess okay okay it's okay though maybe
you'll get some confetti everything will
be alright then Oh block here this is to
weakening to play v3 come on King put
yourself in the line of fire you don't
know your place King I'm floundering
okay pass me rattled beat up a piece as
of a piece mmm night I'd see five how
about that oh I get the a pawn let's
take him out there we go now I could be
up a piece and have now I have no
confidence knight on c4 that's what we
want
there we go
where is he gonna go let's get some
checks get over here
probably had a mate Oh to free rook
get that is this work might actually
work yeah does work
okay back to tournament I got a - 104 84
yeah
only gonna get a lot - more games in
let's see
we might get paired up yeah this game is
uh I think we're going to get another
pairing let's see less than four yes
okay we've played we've played eight
games
let's throw the karo Adam okay at least
I have experience with this line more
than any other
the OL Queen exchange
head adjust my mouse pad there got f5
here we go how to take let's put the
knight on d5 expand with the a pawn
first keep pressure on g4 you could
declare my kings intentions
alright
Knight on f4 they're going to play off
for I want some clarification over here
oh ok yes to move he didn't move oh that
was a mouse lip got the fork let's come
all the way over here preparing b5 no
it's going to lose my rook if I did that
I'm on the bishop they got a trade rooks
this is good clear win doctor tournament
the a pawn was going to run 104 86 okay
at least I got them back 104 8650 for
one more game
to 20 left all right I guess we'll go
one more with this setup so normally
what I do in a hyper bullet alright so I
think that this is this is just some
some quick quick playable stuff that
light is going forward with but I prefer
black here actually I think black is
better hang on to him definitely taken
with the a file or the a pond mmm um
let's come back I think now I need to
stop Knight to f5 alright now I'll take
here jump up these guys are off set
let's trade now night isn't going to
make use of that square I don't know how
good my Bishop is right now improve the
King
um let's see I wanna get an a4 a3 slight
time edge hmm change of plans
oh and see that you get that beep on
though their bishop is out of play
Bishop h3 here h5 there in the think
tank they're not moving
get that pawn this is a really good
square for my Bishop let's reinforce
that get this guy working next he has to
go here I could take with check Oh
let's defend that and break over here
hmm ah got him they resigned back to
tournament and that's going to do it
90s as far as I'm getting 15 seconds
left there won't be another pairing in
this one 104
90 5653 players in this one
mmm tough one it's a lot of fun that's
really intense the elite bullet arena
for 2200 or above and bullet all right
congrats to listener Luke zero zero as
well coming in podium land 104 90
fifty-six assassin and white just barely
out of podium land alright let's see the
other pages two three oh no no it's
shifted on me that one and that's going
to do it alright to the 52 of you the
game's all
tough there's an ice competition there
is awesome